CALL.
CHRIS.
>> Chris: JONATHAN HUNT
REPORTING FROM LAS VEGAS.
JONATHAN, THANKS FOR THAT.
SENATE LEADER MITCH McCONNELL
MADE HISTORY TODAY.
CORRESPONDENT PETER DOOCY TELLS
US HOW.
>> MITCH McCONNELL BECAME
SENATE REPUBLICAN LEADER 11
YEARS FIVE MONTHS AND TEN DAYS
AGO AND NOW HE HAS HAD THE TOP
SPOT A DAY LONGER THAN FORMER
SENATOR BOB DOLE MAKING HIM THE
LONGEST TENURED G.O.P. LEADER
EVER.
>> HE UNDERSTANDS THE SENATE
BETTER THAN ANYBODY ELSE HERE.
>> FORMER SENATOR TRENT LOT HAD
THE JOB FOR FIVE YEARS.
>> I THINK IT WAS THE TOUGHEST
WE ARE SHIPPED OUT, POLITICAL
JOB IN THE CITY.
>> McCONNELL SAYS HE PLAYS THE
LONG GAME.
FAILED TO REPEAL OBAMACARE.
IN 2010 HE TOOK IT FOR OUTLINING
A DIFFERENT PRIORITY.
>> OUR TOP POLITICAL PRIORITY
OVER THE NEXT TWO YEARS SHOULD
BE TO DENY PRESIDENT OBAMA A
SECOND TERM.
>> SIX YEARS LATER WHEN OUTGOING
PRESIDENT BARACK OBAMA MERRICK
GARLAND TO THE COURT, HE
DECLINED TO CONSIDER HIM.
>> THE AMERICAN PEOPLE NEED TO
WEIGH IN AND DECIDE WHO'S GOING
TO MAKE THIS DECISION.
>> DEMOCRATS CRITICIZED HIM FOR
MAKING THIS DECISION.
>> WE ARE SETTING A DANGEROUS
PRECEDENT.
>> McCONNELL LATER HELPED
CONFIRMED NEIL GORSUCH.
>> HE IS REASONABLY ABLE TO
CONTROL HIS PEOPLE.
THAT IN ITSELF IS SOMETHING TO
BE CREDITED WITH.
>> HE'S ALSO THE RARE REPUBLICAN
WHO DARES TO SHARE LAUGHS IN
PUBLIC WITH HIS DEMOCRATIC
COUNTERPARTS.
>> HE PLAYS HIS CARDS CLOSE TO
HIS CHEST BUT HE WILL JUST SIT
THERE AND LISTEN AND LISTEN AND
LISTEN.
>> SOMETIMES REPUBLICANS BREAK
RANKS, LIKE SENATOR TED CRUZ WHO
ONCE CALLED McCONNELL OUT
ABOUT THE EXPORT-IMPORT BANK.
>> I CANNOT BELIEVE HE WOULD
TELL A FLAT OUT LIE.
>> THERE ARE ALSO REPUBLICAN
CANDIDATES WHO TRY TO CAPITALIZE
ON ANTI-McCONNELL SENTIMENT.
>> ONE OF MY GOALS AS U.S.
SENATOR WILL BE TO DITCH COCAINE
MITCH.
>> IN D.C. THERE'S NOT MUCH OF
AN APPETITE TO REMOVE THE
REPUBLICAN LEADER.
>> HE'S BEEN RIGHT SO MANY TIMES
SO IT BUILDS CONFIDENCE.
>> BUT ON THIS, THE DAY THAT
McCONNELL FINALLY BROKE THE
RECORD, HIS OWN MEMBERS AREN'T
LISTENING TO HIM.
MULTIPLE REPUBLICAN SENATORS
HAVE TOLD ME THAT TODAY AT LUNCH
McCONNELL IMPLORED REPUBLICANS
TO STOP BLOCKING REPUBLICAN
AMENDMENTS AND MULTIPLE
REPUBLICAN SENATORS PROCEEDED TO
LEAVE LUNCH AND BLOCK EACH